This I think it would be nicer if you'd
go in that direction.
This is a female chameleon and she has
adopted the typical green coloration
used to match foliage, which I don't
particularly think she's happy because
she started to turn just a little bit
black but if we introduce a friend of hers...
Oh thank you.
Now this is a male chameleon and I'm
very sorry to say that these two
don't get on terribly well together and
I think we might produce a reaction from
the female if we can put the male
reasonably near.
[LAUGHTER]
How about going upwards?
We are seeing a darkening of the female.
It takes a few moments.
This is a social signal.
An aggressive signal from the female in
these circumstances are from they
being watched by a large number of people.
An aggressive signal... Can you see now quite clearly?
And the male as well has also changed his colour.
The darkening of the body, the blotchy black areas on the body.
The animals using the ability to
change its color which it uses usually
for camouflage to communicate to another animal.
That's very clear I think now.
Thank you Bill.
Shall we leave them alone for a while?